[Music]
yo green hola todos entonces para ser lo
mega Dora Y como pruebas Norah's Nozick
we really owe me tan poco nada que no
area yo el mundo esta cambiado
SOF a que cambia Mo's nosotros al gente
que sin kaalia de estas cosas podemos
taco
[Music]
sup guys wait a minute you guys aren't
the real Avengers I can tell hope gives
it away
[Music]
so let's get new top know you've seen
that before knowing with that skirt you
should probably stop staring with Laurie
it's creepy though too late guys are
losers so to become an Avenger other
like trials or any move you just don't
do anything I would do and definitely
don't do anything I wouldn't do there's
a little gray area in there and that's
where you operate oh all right
that's not a hug time just grab the top
for you all right good good luck out
there
listen I know school sucks
Peter you're still with us uh yeah yeah
I know you want to save the world
you have radius you're the Slayer man no
I'm not I'm not this is just costume
this is from the ceiling stay close to
the ground stay out of trouble
forget the flying monster guy there are
people who handle this sort of thing you
couldn't really like a kid all the time
but you are a kid this is my chance to
prove myself
what is going on with you I'm sorry I'm
so busy I'm slam
don't mess with me because I will kill
you and everybody knew blow
probably more or less he said no he said
no look man I don't know who you are but
whoever you're looking for